ん
なんか英語北わかんないけどなんか
ベリーフェイマスって言ってましたねー
2本パックがわかったけれども皆さんが英語を喋れるんでもいいのでえんかなーと思い
ながらちょっとあの恐縮するんですけども
実はの僕放送作家
日本のテレビのバラエティまあお笑いですよね大作家をしてましてですねちょっとまあ
難しいと笑いのこっ
持っていた
えっと
よくねえと質問されずいろんな取材を受けた時に
あのこんなことなんです
違うな間違ったなぁ
まあいいです
そうあの陥っちゃいましたけれどもあっハローいますけども
8笑いはねあのなんで必要かって聞かれるんですよく寝でわれわれは必要なのか人に
とってっていう時に僕いつも言うんですけども
必要かどうかは分からないとそんな言葉
でもね一つずき院は今日今から
今から1回でも笑うと
裸になりますよと
もうそういうルールができたとしましょうで笑った瞬間
燻されると素っ裸にならないといけないですしましょう
そうすると
半日持たないんですよ
絶対笑うんですよ笑っちゃう笑ってそういうもんなんですよ
神様が僕らに与えたもんなんですよなんかね必要かどうかは分からないそんなことは
ただすごく工事体が欲するんですよね
でえええ
北1話の放送作家を長年やってるんで少しはねあの笑いのメカニズム的なことを話さな
あかんだと思って
では第2話さあ今から離しますよこのことについて
笑いには大きく2通りあるんですよ
さあこちらポンッ
初めて見た体でおおおおおおなりてくださいねハッハッ
あの共感と意外性も見てるもんね
分かっ
ある共感というのはあるあるネタ
な日本の方ならわかると思うあるあるネタあとはものまねねっ
モノマネって不思議と思いません俺はれって
にてる中でちょっとおかしいじゃないですか
なんかおかしいでしょででもこれもれすごく重要で実はねじゃあ桑田佳祐さん日本の
有名な
増えますミュージシャ月平成さんのモノマネをするとしましょう
その時に
ちょっとだけしか出ないと住みましょう
した全然ウケないでしょだってその辺のおっさんを立てるだけなって前から
ん
それはそうなんですよただじゃあこれがにていったらいいかと
どんどんどんどんひさしていきましょうどんどんどんどんにさせていくと桑田佳祐さん
そっくりになるとしましょう
これはこうでもと笑えないでしょ
だって困った計付さんですもう
あっそれは不ですよそっくりすぎて笑えないんですだから笑ってねちょっとずれたとこ
にあるんですよね
でこれが共感共感の笑ねもう一個
意外性まあ言葉の通りです多分こうなるであろうなぁと思っていることと違うとが
起こると人って笑うんですよね
よくあるじゃないかそういうことってねあの落とし穴もそうですさああるどすターンと
してはなんでしょ
俺以外舌のはそんな事ないですから世の中ではほとんどないですからね
でこの意外性の話で言うと僕のあの知り合いでコメディアン
芸人さんをやってるほっしゃんっていう人いるんですけども
このほっしゃんが高校の時にここがな柱がございましたけども
テニス部行ったんですよでねその
の10数分で
だらだらだらだらそのプリズムはなんか軟弱なだったんですよね
でそこには後
双子の先輩が言ったのかなで紅夏休みずっと夏の2部練で大変なしで練習してる時に
先生が変わったんですその顧問の先生がでその頃の先生がその練習風景見てもう怒って
もいいんですねもうすごいよだと思うんですよねもうすぐ鼻ぺちゃなる
ダメって言ったんですよ全員に並ばされて左端から
ざーわーバービーとしてたんですよ
で双子んとこ行っても1人目ズバーンとして負担府丹後ぽっちの次のやつはバーンた
路線性をな時間やてぃに変えず一人に弾みとしてるッ
そんなある
でもねもうこれが一番悲惨なのは二山なのは
2発殴られたやつなんですよ
だってねずっと一発やったのになんで俺からに髪やねんとやっぱ嫌こういうことない
意外性の笑ってこういうことなんですよね
大きくこうなるんですで誇りすごいのは
意外性この以外する前にも者の場合ね
すごく悲惨なことが実はスゴイ見てみるかに暴力的なものなんだけども
ほっ者の見方一つで笑いになるでしょでこれってね僕はの言葉のマジックだと思うん
です
だってものすごいものすごい恐怖の子なんかこうなんちのドボン中にてるにそれを笑い
に瞬間に変えてしまうやっぱことはマジックじゃないですか
で
もうちょっと聞いたことあるんだけども
ネガティブなものの中に実はおっぱいが潜んでいることがあるんです
ちょっということかと言いますとねあの
例えば僕はここにいましょうきたら男前の人が2つ++通ってある意味でここに座った
としましょう
で座ってああああそろそろ散髪にからなぁ
言ったとしましょう
普通じゃんですけどそんな何も守れないでしょこれ一応ラテしますけど
なんにも問題ですよ
ただ
頭金ものすぐハゲてる人
ハゲたさんとしましょうこのハゲださんがスタッフたスタートある時て僕の横に
ストーンと育ってそろそろ散歩水かなぁっていうとちょっとだけ面白いじゃないですか
いや失礼なことですよ
もうちょっとだけ面白いでしょ
これどういうことだけどネガティブん中に実は笑いは潜んでるんですよ
なんとなくネガティブ多いところにはなんか笑いがちゃんとあるんですよね
で
そのネガティブな会話もう一なその中にはコンプレックスいうのがあるんですよね
コンプレックスこのコーンブレックス実はコンプレックスと向かい合うと向き合うと
笑いがボルことがあるんです
どういうことかと言いますと
僕の知り合いでデレクたという人がいる
この人まだすごく禿げ上がってるんん
井戸混ぜ北禿の一枚ってられジャンヌ
単純に友達にハゲの人が多いだけなんです
ハゲた人がその彼は大好きなんだけども一緒に番組のかいっぱいあるんですよね
でその彼が
超会議中に女の子が前画面踵で失敗した
そのエトー君ははげてますよそれでトークンはそれがどないしてんと
俺15年ま見てないと
とっ
さあれるだけなしじゃないかといったんです
面白いでしょ
ビックったんです
me ことを言うんですよコンプレックスに向き合った瞬間に笑いに変えたら
これって実は
すごいねー
向き合ってさらけ出すとホこれ
どのん最高の武器になるんですよ
コンプレックスすごい嫌なもんですよこの嫌なもんも実は笑いにするとすごく
らんちゅうの帰り感があっていく
で越冬こういうコンプレックスを笑いに変えている
まあ話事を辛いことを全部欄に書いているそういうことを生業にしている
僕はの芸人さんとよく仕事してるんですよね彼らは実に繊細なんです
ものすごい繊細
やっぱこの技術が
頭はコンプレックスを笑えに打って武器にして戦ってるんですよね
なんで自分のコンプレックスをさらけ出して愛にしたい
なんで俺にはかっちょだってコンプレックスは人に見られたくないし
いじられたくないし嫌じゃないですか
でもねある人がこう言うんです
笑は最も平和的に
瞬間に
人を支配するものでもあると
カロンるっと
だって笑ってしまうんですよ何度か番しても黄色てくれたああっ終わるんですよ
出棺にものすごい匹敵に支配してことになるんですよねでこの支配できた瞬間に自分の
マイナス行ったものをネガティブなものか
笑になって人を支配できるこの瞬間にものすごい幸福を得るんです
だ牛乳さんずっとやってるんです
僕ねあの
僕もそうですが皆さんもそうです殺菌の羽田さんへトークもそうです
ものすごいコンプレックスもっぺん辛いをたくさんあるんですものすごい強いこと
たくさんあるんだけども
でもこれってね実は見方を変えればをライラそのえっ
ですよ
でこれを実は本プレックスに向き合って
そんなかで自分の笑いをつくってしまいはこれ最高の武器にして
幸せになるんです
わかります
ちょっと難しいが言いましたバッハ
少数が仕事自分で言ったような気がしたんですけども
でもねこれ一つポイントがあるそんなにかというと言っ
夕日がないとできぬ
勇気さえあれば向き合えるんです向き合った瞬間に笑いがそこにちゃんとあるんずほっ
といても笑いになっていくん
神様がそうやって心の形に作ってぼ買った出来上がっているんです
どんな人にもそれがあるんですん
スタボいろんな事ありますこれからだ説もあるんでしょう
陣内君という間に3殴り込むし大変です
でもそんなも全部愛の不利なんだん
人生においては笑いの振り税務嫌なこと笑のぶり
そうか言うと笑いで全部回収できるんです
全部回収できるんですよ皆様所です
だから
ほらコンプレックスに向き合って素晴らしい人生に変えてくださいありがとうござい
ました
おっ
そう付くいいじゃんっ
ウェーブ系パワーロスを通す天気沿い持ち